what happens if we introduce dr gears  pocket watch to the clockworks four  clockwork pocket watches belonging to dr  gears were prepared for testing first a  gold-plated watch was placed in 914 on  the setting fine it produced a small  clockwork bird that when its tail was  pressed emitted the sound of a robin's  call next another identical watch was  run through the machine on fine this  time it produced a small toy train  engine powered by clockwork the next  watch run through on fine emerged as a  tiny fully functional grandfather clock  set to eastern standard time the final  watch produced a little metal sculpture  of a piano though each watch was placed  in 914 on the same setting and was made  from the same materials they all  produced a different result the only  common thread was the metal and the  presence of clockwork